oh mein gott was hier abgeordnete diese
ihr schlusswort mich so fertig ich bin
echt mit den nerven am ende
es geht sondern wir kommen zu einer
runde survival games heute mal nicht
aufkomme hd aber dafür mit zwei
bezaubernde boys nämlich oder magix
magix die beiden beschreibung ja auch
sollten euch die von ihnen abgegebenen
bruns geräusche in den nächsten 10
gefallen
dann klicken sie doch mal an und lass
dir dein display da ihr wisst bescheid
danke natürlich spaß immer sie einfach
mal anschauen wenn ihr bock drauf habt
wir zocken heute teams zu beginn ist
warum weil gosch ist wird er uns ohne
also wenn ich eine geschlagene halbe
stunde versucht da irgendwas zu machen
und die ganze zeit auf irgendwas schief
entweder man kann nicht schön aber jetzt
geht's los
oder ich bin entweder mal irgendwann war
ich noch mal im team
ich habe keine freunde hallo hallo ja
ich liebe mit dennis genau wie wir
leider zu dritt sind kann es hier nicht
so team action machen
ich habe mir einfach her die box ist
einfach der keine [ __ ] was verpiss
dich doch alter ohne bin ist was ich mir
denke zum faustkampf missgeburt älter du
rennst jetzt lieber magic hier
denn ist boxen wahrscheinlich dann ist
das doch hast du dein leben verpackt ist
mir folgen
junge migranten faustkampf geliefert was
du irgendwas gerafft alter ja ich habe
mir gerade eine haus kampf gelegt so
dass wir hinterher laufen alter ohne
witz ich sehe dich da bin wo ich dich
ja ich bin durch den alltag helfen
helfen ihr helft mir
die homologen dennis ich nicht dann
ernst ich komme doch hier bin ich das
junge duo echten noch einen nerven
kollaps wegen dir hier folgt mir okay
ich will aber nicht auf die kein elcom
etwas der mit weizen oder was guck mal
der überlebt einfach egal der musste
sterben
den habe ich mit meinem vater gegeben
die hinter bewegungs legastheniker
irgendwie ich auch wer gar nicht so da
hinten ist er darüber was mit dem
partner los als ihr was was war ich
gerade lust hat jetzt zwei versucht mich
zu boxen
newsmax.de müssen soll nichts bekannt da
ging jeder einfach denjenigen im jede
mit jetzt will ich boxe ich muss mir aus
ich muss mir aus ich hab ein herz doch
so ist gibt man irgendwas her bitte
willst deine aufnahme
worauf es mir echt ein zombie daran
gegeben dass andere seine aufnahmen zu
suchen hier ohne waffe ist nicht so
nicht so krass hier auf dem sulgen ist
aber echt echt schwierig deutlich eine
waffe zu finden man findet einfach nicht
ich hab jetzt noch keine lust zum
vibrieren zu essen oder soll ich noch
hinten ist einer erster bleibt man
hinter mir
das bist du bei dieser jungen unfassbar
hängengeblieben leute gebt euch das ist
nicht normal was bei den rechtsstaat
teampartner da ist theater gibt
organisierte super natürlich nichts drin
aber ich nicht diesen vierten stil für
dich leider bin ich dumm ich hab es aber
kaum 12 watt meinem backpack einfach ein
bisschen von mir kommen die mio achtung
jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich finden regen
spinnen regen läuft es gibt auch jans
übrigens hier auf was ist das denn finde
es scheiße verpiss dich du mal übrigens
hier auf dem tod glaube ich leid nach
new york hierauf weist die sache
multituner multipunkt net gibt es hier
die krassesten sachen es ist echt extrem
an hunger games angelehnt es gibt die
distrikts und es passieren hier richtig
abgefuckte sachen liga und ich habe mich
einfach mal gott showdown gott was soll
ich bitte doch im zweiten muss also
jetzt das haben wir nicht gelöst die
leute mit dem feuerzeug
aber unser team partner hatte leider
nicht so die notwendige sagen wenn ich
sagen ja ich bin in ein loch gefallen
und sie haben auf mich eingetreten
ja ganz ehrlich machen dann kannst du
kannst auch nicht sagen welche die
mentalen fähigkeiten abspreche weiß was
richtig gruselig war ich vertut und die
habe ich trotzdem noch beobachtet weiß
was die beste waffe dass mein team hat
martin angeht ja nicht weiter an teilte
islam
ich hab ein scharfes eisen gehört
richtig gut weshalb das war super wo
alter nie im leben hätte ich glaube dass
ich hier noch irgendwann irgendwo
irgendwie land sehe wie es hieß meine
fresse leute was war das wieder runde
einfach nichts gehabt und dann schön im
deathmatch ihr das schafft vertrauen und
ich werde mir diesen kollegen retten so
sag mal was distrikt f-kanal maya graf
dann bin ich ja mein gott was hier
abgeordnete dieses wort mich so fertig
ich bin echt mit den nerven am ende ist
es nicht mit dem fleisch zu essen
fries mit schwert h und er läuft noch
ein jahr
warum glaubst du nicht alle man was ich
würde ich gar nicht ich würde nicht mal
der gleiche gedanke ist kein stresstest
auf jeden fall eine behinderung alles
wie sie wir sind aber gerade weil das
eigentlich viel zu kurz machen noch eine
runde
so leute es gibt noch eine sache
anzumerken und zwar ich bin gerade am
vorproduzieren und deswegen habe ich mir
ja das ist vielleicht noch illegal wenn
ich diese folge jetzt bei knackigen
guten siebenten lasse damit ich einfach
schneller hochfahren kann schnell ändern
kann ihr wisst bescheid in lass mich
kurz schauen
ich will nicht lügen in sieben stunden
fährt man bus es geht nach berlin zum
happy day
deswegen müssen mehr produzieren und da
habe ich natürlich jetzt nicht so viel
zeit die ewig lange vollrausch sonstigen
würde ich sagen euch die folge gefallen
hat dallas ein bäumchen nach oben da
jack die beiden jungs in der
beschreibung ab den komplett behinderten
trainer legen aber doch mit magic beide
dahlems ihr wisst bescheid rein mach's
gut und schön